ici la bonne soupe
l'individu est situé lui aussi puis la
suite si pete a en fait qu'est-ce qui se
passe halim tout de suite la lumière et
ouvre à ces [ __ ] de porte puis la
leur en donner premièrement il faut que
tu continues l'émission tu vas suivre
nos instructions et tu m'a posé aucune
question
troisièmement c'est pour une raison
quelconque
la diffusion est interrompue
tel perrache et c'est quoi ce bordel
deux hommes ont attaqué studio et ils
ont pris clerc et anthony ont deux
tâches et tu raconte ce qui s'est passé
dans un chambre 221 en direct à
l'antenne mais c'est sympa de ma fille
parce que les gars dans ton genre tu
veux que les femmes soient à ton service
qu'elle n'ouvre jamais la wii
andrew qu'est ce que tu as à faire six
filles dans la chambre 221 des baux
dolan
on n'a pas encore fait
c'était censé être simple vraiment très
simple